- We've got Skylar Astin
on the line, give it up.
(audience applauding)
Well, before the break,
we were talking about
how much we rely on the internet
to solve all of our problems
especially in a pandemic.
Autofill saves the most popular
questions we search for,
some of those questions are pretty nuts.
So right now, Skylar and I
are going to try to guess
some of the craziest autofill suggestions.
This is "Autofill and Chill."
♪ Autofill and Chill ♪
- (laughs) That's amazing,
Jessie, you're awesome.
First, we've got to get ready to chill.
I have started, my man,
I have a literal foot
massager massaging my feet
and calves, it's awesome.
I have my wine, I have my fake candles,
oh, I see you've got something
going on too, all right.
What do you have their, candle?
And what is that?
- I got cocktail and candle.
I have a drink that has two ingredients,
one rhymes with latka the
other rhymes with yoda.
(Kelly laughing)
So it's a latkayoda.
- Oh my God!
I love you.
All right, here's the deal,
Skylar and I will each read
the beginnings of two
questions to each other,
we have to guess which of the
three multiple choice options
was a real autofill suggestion
that came up when my producers typed
the beginning of the question
into a search engine.
If Skylar gets more right,
the left side of our house
seats wins a cool prize.
If I get more correct,
which will probably happen,
the prize goes to the right side.
I'm all talk, man, I usually lose a lot,
(laughs) and it's always--
- I like the competitive
vibe, I gotta be honest.
- I am super competitive,
I'm bringing that every time,
even when I lose.
And as always, if Skylar wins,
he will have his photo mounted
on the Blake Shelton wall of champions
who beat Kelly Clarkson.
It's a great wall, my man.
You're never gonna grace it.
- Now I'm really scared.
- Lets say you should, it's an honor.
(laughs) I'll read the first
one for Skylar, here we go.
Help, I'm obsessed with,
and then A, the Kardashians,
B, potatoes or C, stamp collecting.
So, which was the most popular search?
- Stamp collectors, I don't
imagine that they like have,
they got their stuff figured out.
It's such a novel thing I don't
think they need to search.
You know what I mean?--
- I kind of hope it's
stamp collecting but,
okay, which one?
- And then Kardashians,
I've never really watched the Kardashians
but I know they're insanely popular.
However, I feel like with potatoes
and I know it's a random one,
I feel like people are constantly trying
to repurpose potatoes whether
it's frying, or baking,
or doing fun things.
So, it's between Kardashians and potatoes,
and for no reason I think I'm gonna go
with potatoes actually.
- I really hope it's pot--
(bell dings)
Oh, it's right, you got it right.
(audience cheering)
Yes, I would've said stamp collecting
just cause it was random,
but you're right.
They probably have got their
stuff figured out, it's okay.
Okay, the next one is for
me, what's my question?
- Your question is,
help, my kids won't stop,
A, eating, B, stop pooping or C, shut up.
- I mean, every parent
in the world knows it's C
but (laughs) this just won't shut up.
My mom likes to call it karma for me,
well, I don't know, I
figure all of those are,
'cause one of my kids
won't eat like anything,
unless it's beige.
And then they stop pooping,
I figure that's what you
would Google as a parent
because you're like, is
there something wrong?
Should I take them to a doctor?
I'm gonna go with, shut up.
Help, my kids won't shut up.
Like, what is there to do?
I feel like this was searched a lot
during the pandemic specifically,
I'm gonna say shut up.
(bell dings)
Oh, I'm right! (screams)
- You got it, it's a tie score.
- Honestly, my heart said it was shut up
but I thought it was
gonna be something else
but I just needed to say shut up
'cause that is happening
a lot in the pandemic.
You're like, just be quiet for a minute.
Okay, the last one for Skylar,
which way do I,
A, put on the toilet paper roll?
B, turn the hose,
oh, which way do I turn the hose?
Or C, swipe on Tinder (laughs).
Which was most popular?
- So, I feel like you don't really consult
a search engine about Tinder,
I think you maybe consult friends like,
"Hey, what am I supposed
to do, left or right?"
So I'm gonna just like, ditch that one.
The hose is actually odd
because you would think
it would go to the right, but
it actually goes to the left,
I've learned this the hard way,
but why would you go search that?
Yeah, it actually goes the opposite way.
- I feel like my hose, you
turn off, goes to the right.
- Well now it feels like
there's actually debate
with both of these
things, whether it's okay.
I'm gonna go with my gut, literally,
and I'm gonna go with A,
I'm gonna go with toilet paper.
(bell dings)
- Oh, you got it right!
- Yes!
(all applauding)
- Yes, I think we've all figured out
that the right answer is over the top,
end of discussion, okay (laughs).
Okay, well what's my last one?
- Okay, your last one
is how much is too much?
A, wine, B, chocolate, or
C, time spent on my phone.
- Okay, once again my
heart says there is not,
there's never too much for A or B, what?
How, who Googles that?
Anybody that's having
wine does not wanna Google
how much is too much wine?
And that just depends on who you are
and how your body reacts to wine.
And chocolate, let's just be real,
it's bad for you, but
it's freaking awesome.
So like whatever, who Googles that?
And if you're Googling how
much is too much chocolate,
we can't be friends.
I'm gonna say C, time spent on my phone.
(screen buzzing)
Oh, what was it?
- The correct answer is actually wine.
- What do you mean?
I mean, obviously, you
know when it's too much
when someone's holding your hair.
(all laughing)
- Exactly, you can't even see straight
to go to like check it out, you're like,
"How much is too much?"
- Yeah, who does that?
And who is drunk like, searching
how much is too much wine?
You're no fun.
Okay fine, whatever.
Okay, that means that
the winner is Skylar,
and the left side of the house
seats gets the cool prize.
But because, well, it's my show
and it's January 15th, what the hell!
everyone's a winner,
So Nextbase makes dash
cams that protect drivers
by recording the road ahead
with super cool like, clear
footage in all conditions.
Their 322GW version also
comes with Alexa built in
so you can keep your hands on the wheels
and it detects incidents
even when you're not driving
which is also awesome.
So you're all going home with a 322GW.
(audience applauding)
For everybody you can catch
Zoe's extraordinary playlist,
Tuesdays on NBC and
streaming anytime on Peacock.